[Music]  the filmmakers who are nominated for  this year's cassavetes award we're all  here today because  we made beautiful meaningful films for  under 500 000  we filmed in our actual apartment and we  filmed in friends apartments and i think  it has this lived-in feel that  it wouldn't have had for millions of  dollars i have the benefit of being a  teacher  i begged some of my students to come on  board  i sent like a blind email to like info  at skywalker they watch like the  roughest rough cut and just like  we'd love to have a call there are  people after a screening and saying i  had absolutely no idea that this was  going on  having that discussion was was enough  for me such a surreal you know almost  kind of like spiritual experience it's  kind of like even just shooting the  project  not only can you choose what story you  want to tell but you can tell it in your  own way  the truly independent of the independent  spirit of words